- Don't stay in tomorrow.
You've got to at some point
move from tomorrow to right now.
You can't just sit at home
and imagine a Lamborghini
and it pulls up into the driveway
and somebody gives you the keys.
What if your default emotion
was gratitude, all the time.
What if it was joy all the time.
Now you might get pushed and
get stressed out for a minute,
but you come back to joy.
What doesn't kill you,
does make you stronger!
That doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt, it hurts,
but it makes you stronger.
- He's been a leader in the
network marketing industry
for almost 30 years.
He's built a sales organization totaling
over 500,000 distributors
in over 60 countries.
He's the author of the international
bestselling book, Go Pro.
He's Eric Worre, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules to success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the
comments below and put quotes
around it so that other people
can be inspired as well.
Also, as you are writing something down,
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy.
(loud wind blowing)
(upbeat energetic music)
(electronic beeping)
- Tomorrow, some day,
next week, I'm about to.
This is the language that I
hear a lot in network marketing.
Tomorrow I'm going to get started.
Tomorrow I'm going to
schedule some appointments.
After the weekend I'm
really going to kick it.
When the new month starts,
I'm going to make it happen.
Once I get past this birthday,
then I'm really going to take off.
Once the kids get out of school,
then I'm going to focus on this.
Once the kids get back into
school, after the summer break,
then I'm going to do it.
After the holidays, then
I'm going to make it happen.
Now here's the thing.
People do a lot of talking,
and one side of proclaiming
what you're going to do is very good,
telling the world what you're about to do.
Telling them something
that you haven't done yet,
that's a very healthy
thing 'cause it'll hold you
accountable to those statements,
but don't get stuck there.
Don't stay in tomorrow,
you've got to at some point
move from tomorrow to right now.
Move from the action that
you're going to do on Monday,
to right now.
Not even today, because
that gives you all the time
until the end of the day.
You've got to move your clock,
when you think about here's
one thing I need to do,
I need to schedule more appointments,
I'm going to do that right now.
Right now, the first available
moment I have to do it,
I'm going to do it right now.
I'm going to start right now, I'm
going to get moving right now.
Because a lot of you are
listening to this stuff,
and that's great, listening is great.
Understanding is even better,
action is even better than understanding.
You can have the most
knowledgeable person in the world,
but if they keep saying tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow,
they're never going to get the results
that they're looking for,
so guess where most of the learning
and most of the real
understanding comes from.
In the doing.
A lot of people think that
they understand network
marketing, and they can
never understand what it is
that you do every day because
they've never done it.
You understand, really, on a
cellular level, when you do it.
And if you continue with
action, you'll start
to get results from those actions.
'Cause it's not just in the doing once,
it's the doing and then refining,
and doing again and then refining.
Work getting better every single day.
Understanding that you can't look good
and get better at the same time.
Being willing to be uncomfortable,
being willing to get outside
of your comfort zone.
Being willing to go from a tomorrow person
to a right now person.
My future plan is about this thick, typed.
It's usually about 40 page or so,
and it includes everything.
And today more than ever, what
you'll find with top leaders,
what you'll find with successful people,
is they're forward thinking,
they're future thinking,
and that future starts to pull them
towards those objectives.
So I set my goals pretty
high, and I set my calendar
far in advance, I'm planning,
I still have some spontaneity,
room for spontaneity,
but more and more as
the demands on my time
are growing exponentially, I have to plan.
And what I've, I've done
this for, gosh, 25 years,
so look back and look forward.
Look back take inventory, be honest,
and look forward and map it out.
So I want you to think
about short term, mid term,
long term goals, for you
personally and for your team.
Create an environment that
supports your goals, your dreams.
What do I mean by that,
make sure the people
around you are pushing you
in the direction of your dreams,
not patting you on the back
for doing less than you're
capable, but pushing you
to do more.
Make sure the things
you're feeding your mind
are pushing you in the
direction of your dreams.
Make sure that you're
protecting your mind from things
that would distract you from your dreams.
It's your job, it's your
job, to create a bubble,
to create an environment,
to create this ecosystem
that will support your goals.
Because if you're surrounded by people
that are constantly distracting you,
it's going to be very
difficult for you to grow
a network marketing business.
If you're surrounded by
people who are patting you
on the back for doing one
tenth of what you're capable of
instead of pushing you and challenging you
and getting in your face,
then there's only so far you can go.
If you're constantly feeding
your mind and allowing
your mind to be infected
by negative pessimistic
compromising thoughts, then you can guess
what your results are going to be.
So guess who's job, it's not,
you're not trying to
look for an environment
that will support you,
your job is to create an
environment that will support you.
Create this community
around you, create the right
friendships, the right mentoring,
the right coaching, the right ideas,
the right encouragement,
the right challenge,
for you to be able to
go where you need to go.
You understand what I'm saying?
So, it's your job to hold
yourself accountable and create
systems to hold yourself
accountable to a higher standard.
Your dreams are worth it, I promise.
If you're frustrated
and you don't know why
you can't take action,
this is the big reason why.
You can't seem to get
things going, this is why.
So one, determine those
dreams, get 'em lock solid.
Two, hold yourself
accountable towards 'em.
And three, create a system around you
of people and influences around you,
that will challenge
you, that will push you,
that will force you sometimes
to do the things necessary
to make your dreams a reality.
I've had to evolve so many
times, I've had to change
and grow so many times.
There's been times when
I've made such huge mistakes
in my network marketing career.
Damaged relationships, done
things that I wish I could
go back and change, but I couldn't.
So I could either live
there, or I could use that
information to grow and become better.
See I've been involved for
25 years and I promise you,
every year that you, that we're engaged,
we're working together, every
year you're going to see me
get a little bit better,
and most of the time I'm
not going to hit my goals,
but then I'm going to
get a little bit better,
and a little bit better,
and compounded over time,
you'll see noticeable results.
Anybody who knows me knows
that I'm a different person
than I was five years ago, 10 years ago,
15 years ago, certainly 25 years ago.
18 jobs, you know, barely surviving,
so give yourself some grace.
Understand that nothing is ever finished
while you're still alive.
But here's what I believe
is the most powerful force,
one of the most powerful forces on earth,
and that is your imagination.
What you can imagine.
Now most people misuse their imagination,
in other words, they think about
what bad things could happen.
They let their imagination
go wild to the negative side.
How they could get hurt,
how they could get rejected,
what could, you know,
all the terrible things
that could happen.
But the most successful
people, and I will tell ya
I've used this in my life
for my whole life and it's,
well my whole adult career at least,
and it's worked unbelievable,
is using your imagination for good.
Using it for growth.
Now here's what I mean by that.
If you pick a goal, whatever it is,
let's say you want to
meet someone, let's say
you want to achieve a rank,
let's say you want to get
to an income goal, let's say
you want to have a certain
number of people in your group
at the next company event,
whatever it is, okay?
I want you to clearly
imagine it, get it so clear
in your mind that it's like
you're living it in reality.
What does it look like,
what does it feel like,
what does it smell like,
what does it taste like,
as clear as you can get it.
And when you're talking
about what this picture
in your mind,
it's good to put it in
writing, and it's good
to make it as detailed
as you possibly can.
How do you feel now that
you've achieved that goal?
How many lives are you
impacting now that you've
accomplished that
objective, whatever it is,
doesn't matter what it is.
But the key is detail,
the key is specifics.
The key is a clear, crystal
clear mental picture.
So get it clear, and then
just go about your life,
but here's, what ends up
happening and it's happened
to me so many times
you can't even imagine,
as soon as I get it clearly in my mind,
it's not long before that
thing becomes a reality.
Now it's not a magic trick, okay?
You can't just sit at home
and imagine a Lamborghini
and it pulls up into the
driveway and somebody
gives you the keys,
it's not a magic trick like that.
Here's why I believe it works.
Your subconscious brain
is working all the time,
no matter what you're doing.
It's working, it's helping
you guide and shift
and make different decisions,
but if you get a clear
picture in your mind,
I believe you unlock the power
of your subconscious mind.
And when you unlock the power
of your subconscious mind,
it starts to grind and
grind and grind and grind,
to make the picture that you have
in your imagination a reality.
And there starts to be
thousands of what I like to call
micro-decisions that start to happen.
Little left turn right turn,
little course corrections,
thousands of them, that
are happening all the time.
While you sleep, your
subconscious brain is working
to help guide you towards that objective.
If you're mowing the lawn,
if you're doing the laundry,
that subconscious mind is
working, if your imagination
is strong enough and clear
enough, your subconscious mind
is working and working and
grinding and grinding and moving,
it's not like you're
attracting those things to you,
you're attracting yourself to those things
because your subconscious
mind is working for you.
It's like a slave for you,
working and grinding and working
and grinding and working and grinding
to help you get to your objective.
Thousands and thousands
of little decisions
you didn't even know why you
made them, they were made
because one, you had a
clear picture in your mind.
Two, your subconscious brain went to work
without you even realizing it.
And three, step by step, inch
by inch, you moved closer
to your objective until you attained it.
So the picture that you have in your mind
is incredibly important
because guess what,
if you have negative picture in your mind,
a negative picture in your imagination,
your subconscious mind's
going to go to work
to make that a reality too.
Thousands of little
micro-decisions to guide you
towards the negative.
So, who wants to live with that?
Who wants to put your
subconscious mind to work
as your employee to work for
you and work against you?
Why would you want to do that?
So get a clear picture of your
goals, of your objectives,
of your vision of anything
you want to accomplish,
anyone that you want to meet,
anything that you want to do.
I've envisioned getting on a stage
that I wanted to speak on.
I've envisioned having
thousands of people in the room.
I've envisioned relationships
with top of my heroes
of personal development, with Jim Rohn's
and the Tony Robbin's,
and the Richard Branson's
and all the different people.
I've imagined those relationships
long before they became a reality.
And then my subconscious
mind went to work.
And it ground, it was grinding
and grinding and grinding
and grinding, thousands of decisions
until it became a reality.
So one, think of something
that's important to you,
get it clear in your mind,
and then let your subconscious
mind grind for you, let it work for you,
let it create results for you.
In this book, the one that I was just
reading over the weekend,
he talks about the fact
that you know what,
if times are bad for you right now,
if the wind is blowing
in your face right now,
just hang in there because
the wind can change.
The wind will change, and
if the wind's in your face,
the wind can change and be
on your, be at your back
and propel you forward
and I really struggled
with this message, I really
had a difficult time with it
because I've listened
to so much of Jim Rohn,
and because if you know anything at all,
which I'm an amateur,
but if you know anything
at all about sailing,
it doesn't matter what the wind is doing,
if it's at your back or
if it's in your face,
there is a way for you to move forward.
If the wind is in your face
and you have a sail boat,
you just go back and
forth and back and forth,
using that same wind to go forward.
I will tell you, there's a group of people
who are crossing their fingers today
and they're waiting
for the wind to change.
There's a group of people
who are hoping and praying
that the wind changes, and
what I want to tell all of you,
if you're, if any of those people are you,
is you don't need to wait
for the wind to change.
The wind, whichever way it
blows, can be your friend.
If it's in your face, you
have a different approach
to how you move forward.
If it's from the side, you
have a different approach
to how you move forward.
If it's at your back, there's
going to be times when it's
at your back, sure, everybody
can move forward quickly
when the wind's at your back.
But when it's not, and
it's not most of the time,
you have to have a
strategy to move forward.
We can change the sail and we can have
total control regardless of the wind.
We can decide which
direction we're going to go
regardless of the wind.
We don't have to wait
for something out there
to happen in order for us to be okay.
It's not out there ladies
and gentlemen, it's in here.
It's not out there, it's in here.
So not only do you need to
take charge when it comes
to setting the sail of your life,
we need to let the whole
world know, while they're all
waiting for this wind to
change, and it might and it may
change, but of course at some
point it's going to change,
but it may not change for
some people for a long time.
We can give them an opportunity
and the skills to be able
to prosper regardless of
the direction of the wind.
Do you get what I'm saying to you?
It's not out there ladies and gentlemen,
it's right in here.
Once you get that, you realize
how much power you actually
really have in controlling
the direction of your life,
everything'll change for you.
Instead of focusing just on
the how, one of the skills,
not only just the tactical
skills of how to do things,
but the skills of
understanding the human element
of what it is that we do.
If you know why you need to
use your own product or service
every single day, then it's
easy to develop structures
for everybody to learn how to do that.
If you know why it's
important to build your story,
if you know why it's important
to go to your events,
to share the opportunity,
if you know why it's important
to utilize third party tools,
if you know why it's important to
be able to give a strong testimonial,
if you know why it's important to focus on
personal development,
then the how to gets easy,
and if you know why, and you
get that why strong enough,
you can help all those
people that have been
in assignment oriented
living for their whole life,
in other words they've been doing
what they're told their whole life,
a lot of people are waiting
for somebody like you
who understands why it
is that we do what we do,
to be able to inspire those
people to start to do it,
to do the how to, and then eventually
they'll develop the why to.
Once I understood this concept of the why,
the person who knows how to
do something will always work
for the person who knows why to something,
well I don't want to work for
anybody the rest of my life.
What I want to do is I want to focus on
why am I doing everything?
Why does this work in network marketing,
why does this not work
in network marketing?
I understood all of the
mechanical, psychological triggers
that made our business
work, and once I understood
the why's not only did
the how's get easy for me,
but it became very easy for me to inspire
other people to take action.
Because I understood the true
reasons why to do something,
I wasn't just saying
do it 'cause I said so.
I could explain that philosophy to them.
I switched my mind from
becoming the best how to guy
that you would ever meet,
to becoming the best
why to guy that you'll ever meet.
Changed my business, changed my life.
I will tell you, if you
implement this in your business,
it'll change yours too.
You can't afford to mow your lawn,
what does that title even mean?
Let me back up and give
you some context to it,
and I think by the end of this show,
you're going to agree with me.
If you're involved in network marketing,
if you're an entrepreneur,
you can't afford to mow your lawn.
Now here's where this all started for me.
I've been mentored by a
few different billionaires
over the course of my career.
And the first one, I
went to him and I said,
"You know, I want to achieve,
I want to move forward,
"you've had all this
success, what do I do,
"how do I break out, how do I create
"more success for myself?"
He said, "Eric, how much do
you want to make in a year,
"give me a number."
I said, "Well, a million
a year sounds good,
"you know, two commas, a
million dollars a year.
"That sounds like it would
be, you know, a great life."
He said, "Fine,"
he said, "That's a good start.
"Let's break that down.
"To make a million dollars a year,
"you would have to earn
approximately $500 an hour
"in your work time.
"$500 an hour in your work time,
in order to be able to earn
"a million dollars a year."
He said, "Eric, is there
a task that you can do
"in your business, that will earn you
"$500 an hour over time."
I went, "Well, in network
marketing, there actually is."
If I'm in front of a prospect,
if I'm tellin' the story,
if I'm sharin' the product,
I'm tellin' the story,
I'm sharing the
opportunity, I'm explaining
the compensation plan,
I'm with a prospect,
helping them understand what
it is that I have to offer,
if I'm with that prospect, that over time,
equals $500 an hour or better.
That was my experience.
I just didn't spend that much time
in front of that many prospects, right?
I would, I'd get, my life was
busy with everything else.
I said, "Yeah," I said,
"Yes, I have that activity."
He said, "Fine."
He said, "take every
activity that you are doing,
"that's, that you, that can
be done by someone else,
"number one, the activity that
can be done by someone else,
"number one, number two, is
worth less than $500 an hour,
"and number three, isn't something
"that's jeapordizing your
family or your values,
"and have somebody else do it."
So, I said, "So, wait a
minute, so, I mow my lawn,
"you're telling me I can't mow my lawn?"
He said, "You can mow your
lawn, but mowing your lawn
"is minimum wage activity.
"If you want to sell your
hour for minimum wage,
"and there's a task you
could do somewhere else
"that's paying $500 an
hour, why would you do that?
"Call it $15 an hour to mow your lawn,
"and you have a task
that you could get $500
"if you're in front of prospects?
"Every time you mow your
lawn, you lose $485."
And I went, "Wow.
"I thought I was saving
money by mowing my lawn."
No, it was costing me
money to mow my lawn.
So here's what I did.
I took inventory of every part of my life.
I currently, and for decades
now, have not done tasks
of under $500 an hour, unless it was
something with my family,
unless it was something that I chose to do
that was quality with the
relationships in my life,
I'm talking about work time,
I'm talking about time,
think tasks that I could do,
that don't impact my relationships, okay?
So, I don't mow the lawn.
I don't clean the pool.
I don't clean out the garage.
I don't get groceries.
I don't clean the house.
I don't do any of that stuff.
In our family we have people
help us do those things,
and then we focus our tasks, our energy,
on the highest producing
activity possible.
Mastering your emotions,
and people ask me sometimes,
like, are emotions
important for entrepreneur?
Managing emotions, does that important,
seems like it would be all
discipline and hard work.
Well guess what will cause
you to stay disciplined,
and will cause you to do the hard work,
is mastering your emotions.
Trying to figure out that the
triggers that cause you to act
or cause you to freeze,
and one of the most interesting
concepts, and I learned
this from Tony Robbins, he and
I were talking this last year
several times about this
concept, it's so interesting,
and that is, what is your default emotion?
In other words, when poked, when prodded,
when bored, when either
stimulated or not stimulated,
what emotion is your go to emotion?
Now, for some people, it's stress.
Entrepreneurs, a lot of
entrepreneurs like to go,
"I'm stressed out, I'm
just stressed right now."
That's their go to emotion.
They go into their mind and
that is, that's what they go to
as a default.
That's their neutral, okay?
Some people, use worry to
worry about something that
might happen, worry about what
somebody else might think,
worry about some circumstance
outside of their control.
Worry about what's going
on with their comp plan,
or worry about what's
happening with the product,
or worrying about what's going on
with the international expansion,
or worrying about decisions
the team is making,
or the company is making, or worrying
about an event that's
coming up, or something,
that's their default emotion.
Some people it's to fight,
their default emotion is anger.
They want to fight, they're
looking for an enemy all the time.
That's their default emotion, okay?
So we all have a choice,
and we all have to decide
what is the default emotion
that's going to serve us,
and is the current one
that we have the one
that's serving us the most?
Because if it's on the negative side,
stress, frustration, doubt, worry, anger,
all of those, which
many entrepreneurs have,
if we, if our default is
there, inside of that space,
it's like putting a
limiter on our potential.
When we're in that space,
do you think we are
attracting people to us, or do you think
we may be pushing some people away?
Are we making people want
to be around us a lot,
are we maybe only attracting
other angry people,
or other stressed out people
that we can relate to?
So, there's a choice.
There's another range of emotions,
now that doesn't mean you
can't bounce into stress,
which is just fear, you
can't bounce into anger,
or defending somebody, or something,
you can't bounce into
frustration or worry or doubt,
but what's the default,
where do you go back to?
What's center, what is neutral for you?
And, for me, it was an
interesting exercise to kind of
go through this, as like wow,
because when I was talking
with Tony about it, he was
saying that he has so much
going on in his life, that it's very easy
for stress to become he default emotion.
So, he finally realized
that no, no that's a choice.
I could choose to look at something,
anything part of my life
and get stressed about it,
but my default emotion, could I replace
that default emotion for passion?
For joy, for happiness, for gratitude?
Those default emotions.
What if your default emotion
was gratitude, all the time?
What if it was joy all the time?
Now you might get pushed and
get stressed out for a minute,
but you come back to joy,
you come back to gratitude.
You come back to happiness.
Right?
You come back to passion.
And there's a difference
between passion and anger.
If it's anger, that's going
to repel a lot of people.
If it's passion, it's going
to attract tons of people
into your life, into your world.
So, I want you to think about
what your default emotion is,
maybe even write down, what
is the emotion that you go to
most when poked, when
something doesn't go perfect,
when something unexpected
happens, when stressed.
What is your default emotion, where do you
go to there, okay?
And just aside, that on the
other side of that coin,
instead of expectation and anxiety,
it can be appreciation and gratitude.
Instead of anger, it can be passion.
Instead of worry and doubt,
it can be joy and peace.
That it's all going to be fine.
So, we control this.
We might not be able to control the pain,
that we talk about this at
Go Pro Recruiting Mastery
we talk about this more and more,
we might not be able to
control physical pain,
or mental emotional pain,
but we can choose
suffering, that's a choice.
The pain might not be a choice,
but the, our emotional state is a choice.
The one thing that Tony told
me that just knocked me down,
is he and I both go up on stage
and we give a lot of energy
and we're, you know,
we're very enthusiastic,
we're very energetic,
and then for me, when I get
off the stage, I like woo,
I throttle back a bit,
I reset my batteries,
so my stage energy is not my
default, it's an exception.
So he told me, he said,
Eric, the biggest change
to happen in his life, he
said to me, when we were
doin' an interview this
last year, he said,
"Eric the biggest change
to happen to me in my life
"this last year, was I
decided to take the guy
"that's on stage, I decided
to take him home with me.
"And that was going to be my new default."
And I went, "Wow, okay.
That's something completely different."
Think about you and your
best energetic state,
your most attractive, your most outgoing,
your most vibrant state possible,
think about taking that
person home with you.
Think about that being your new normal.
Think about that being kind
of the, just a, every day,
and the other negative stuff
is just kind of here and there,
it just comes and it goes.
But you have a different default state.
Control that default state, you start
to take control of your life.
All entrepreneurs deal with
this issue of self-doubt,
of challenge, of difficulty, of struggle.
And, I don't know what
it is for you, I mean,
for me I, so many things
went through my mind.
Maybe this isn't for me.
Maybe this just isn't my thing.
Maybe other people are made
for this, maybe I'm not.
Maybe entrepreneurs need to be born,
'cause I wasn't born an entrepreneur,
maybe I just need to be
realistic and just go get a job.
Maybe I don't have the
discipline for this.
Or some days when I would just
say, you know, I would get
so discouraged with people,
because I couldn't get people
to do the actions that
I was willing to do,
maybe I'm just not a good enough leader.
Maybe the product isn't,
you know, valuable enough.
Maybe the compensation plan doesn't pay
as much as I think it should.
Maybe I'm in a country
or a part of the world
that is, you know, I
feel is more resistant
to network marketing than
any other part of the world,
you know, so because of
that I'm going to struggle.
Or whatever, there's, the list is so long,
when it comes to reasons to check out.
Reasons to walk away.
You miss that rank,
you push for that goal,
you get embarrassed, you fall on your face
in front of your group, you try and do
a presentation it doesn't go very well,
you drive across town, you
go across the country even,
to do a meeting and nobody shows up,
somebody in your company
makes you feel bad
or makes you feel small,
and because of that
you get your feelings hurt.
There's so many reasons to quit.
And here's my message for you this week.
If you're looking for a reason
to quit, they're all there.
I just gave you a whole bunch of them.
There's a whole menu of
reasons that you can choose,
and no one will blame you.
You can say hey, because of
this, I decided not to do it,
and that makes you feel
better, and that explains it
to the world, and you
move on with your life.
There'll always be a reason to quit.
But, if your dream is strong enough,
there will always be a reason to stay.
There will always be a
reason to push through.
reason to help others.
Maybe it's knowing that
your product or service
is going to be, have
an impact on the world
and you can't let that go.
Or maybe it's you're rescuing
people from desperate lives,
maybe it's taking care
of those family members
that maybe can't take care of themselves
as well as maybe you can help them do,
maybe it's giving to the causes
that are important to you.
Maybe it's seeing that
next person in your group,
the fire light up in their
eyes, because of you,
because you persevered, because you worked
when no one else was watching,
because you decided to do something
that other people weren't willing to do.
That sense of pride
that you did something,
that sense of pride that
you went through the battle,
the sense of pride that
you stood for something.
That's more valuable in my opinion,
than living a life full of regrets.
Going through the challenge, understanding
the challenge is what
makes something of you.
The challenge is what
creates something of you.
They say what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger,
I think that's true.
What doesn't kill you
does make you stronger!
That doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt, it hurts.
But it makes you stronger.
And I will tell you, it's
the struggle for the past,
since 1988, when I got
involved in network marketing,
it's the struggle that forced me to become
the person that I am today, and I'm proud
of the person that I am today.
Without the struggle, if
it would have been easy
every single day, I
wouldn't have become much.
I would have been just an immature idiot
running around with money,
versus somebody who's learned and grown,
and expanded and gotten better.
Because, even though I had those
days when I wanted to quit,
I found a reason to stay.
I found a reason to keep going,
I found a reason to work through my fears.
I found a way to conquer the struggle.
So I don't know where
I find you on this day,
when this message finds you,
but if it's landing on you
on a particularly bad day,
just understand this.
There's always a reason to quit,
but there's also always a reason to stay.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Josue O'Remiggio asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Eric say
that had the biggest
impact on you, what are you
going to take from this video,
that you're going to
immediately apply to your life
or to your business?
Leave it in the comments, I'm
going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Total Greatness,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting
that fun picture to Instagram,
I really really really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, hope you
continue to believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love,
I'll see you soon.
(loud wind blowing)
- That Jim Rohn had a
major impact on my life
by implanting these ideas,
the power of an idea,
these ideas into my mind.
Self-education will make you a fortune.
So a formal education,
everybody goes through,
you kind of have to go through that.
But what are you going to do
after formal education is done?
Self education will make you a fortune.
And I went, wow, okay.
He was the one that had me start, cause I,
back then, if I read any book,
within about two pages I
was ready to go to sleep.
I was just exhausted, you know, just like.
(fake snoring)
But he said, "Eric, just start
by reading 10 pages a day.
"Find a book that interests
you, read 10 pages a day.
"You can get through a 300
page book in a month if you
"do that, and start to
develop the discipline."
Because I started just
listening to audio programs.
I did not have any discipline to read.
And he made me become a reader, he said,
"Readers are leaders."
Self education, what are you
doing to improve your skills
all the time, are you taking charge?
And I'm, one of the
things I'm most proud of,
is how much I've educated myself
since I left formal education.
How much I've educated myself,
how many books I've read,
how many seminars I've gone to,
how many skills I've
worked on and developed,
how many coaches I've had and
mentors I've had in my life
in order to be able to get better.
Self education will make you a fortune,
formal education will make you a living,
you get a paycheck.
Self education, you get
to be financially free.
I've read probably two
books a week on average
for the last 20 plus years.
So, it's a lot of books, a lot of books.
Why?
Because Jim Rohn taught me that
self education will make you
a fortune, and if you stop
growing, you start dying.
So I want to continue
in that growth pattern.